um i i again i'm a man of god this is a
perfect time to bring this up because
we've read this before
but i wanted to read this again okay i
was saying that how terrible we are he
has kids whatever okay we rece by the
way this isn't
not an email that we received um
recently this is an email that we
received a month ago we received this
email a month ago january 12 2019 a
little over a month ago okay
i'm not going to say his name because
i'm not doug i'm not
so he sent me this this thing okay so
i'm gonna read this verbatim this is
from one a former bear
hey guys discovered you this is through
the suggestions because of owen benjamin
and you were right he's gone nuts and
paranoid i've actually been hate
watching your videos until it happened
to me what happened
until the big bear turned on me and you
guys were right
on his recent thing about the actor of
aquaman allegedly being a pedophile
adjacent memo he's referring to
i defended the actor talked about a long
video with more context a guy's history
and you know the whole idea of innocent
until proven guilty
owen is pretty set on sending the guy
off to prison or wanting worse for the
short clip
we don't need to debate whether the
actor is or isn't this is just the
context of the story
so i defended him and i got owen's new
vague maybe slightly threatening
response
you are known for what you are obviously
i got a bunch of responses
from other bears cussing me out on a
side note i've already been taking a
break from one for a couple weeks but i
realize how deep this goes
i know i didn't want to watch anymore if
it had just stayed like that i would
have left it
but then he decided to screenshot my
comment and his response and then make
another post my username
pictures and all changed them now and i
was
check this out he already had a private
account
his account was private so somebody did
that for him although others have
commenting saying so
i deleted my comments because he got
scared because this is what he's used to
people doing of course
i and i don't blame him i deleted my
comments if you are willing i would
request you remove your post with me i
know i was already uh commenting quickly
this is what he sent him oh
okay this is the email he sent owen owen
i've retracted my comments
if you are willing i would request you
remove your post with me
i know i was already commenting publicly
but please i asked for a removal
if you don't i can't do anything so i
guess i'll just accept it
i'm asking kindly and i'll make sure i
think longer before posting publicly
that is what he sent owen okay i don't
blame him
17 year old kid i understand but just so
you know
this is what owens used to uh he goes on
of course he didn't remove the post why
would he this really ticks me off you
know
the thing is i'm just a miner
i've only seen one commentator who could
tell uh
so it is like public is is he's asking
so is it like public slander for a minor
over these things
i'm going to wait to see if anything
continues with my name if i just stay
here if i if it just stays here for
tonight
it'll be the move from owen and forget
unfortunately i have to pay attention
for a bit to see if it continues
uh with my name in this case well i
don't really know but public slander of
me as a minor
slander of pedophilia related whatever i
just don't need or especially want that
especially since unfortunately we live
in a world where social media
uh social media people can pull stuff
from years to use against you
uh and i will be more public as a job as
an adult
i guess i can simply say i'm going to be
a pastor
man of god owen benjamin uh it feels
like something so
petty to take action for but also it
ticks me off
maybe it'll just uh a sign that i should
get off social media
so uh i don't know i'm rambling at this
point just thought i'd share this
another ex bear story since he's
probably not going to take it down
you can go look at it yourself i don't
really agree with a lot of your opinions
which is fine
and i'm not going to jump on one
bandwagon to the next but
you were totally right on this owen
benjamin thing i'll keep an eye out on
this channel thanks
from a ticked off ex bear
so he's been nice to people he's been a
good guy 17 year old kid
who wanted to be a pastor but i forgave
him
he forgave him after [ __ ] up his life
uh that's that's what that's how owen
benjamin
is a man of god folks